are you bored of talking about social
justice
um in one way no
because they're so endlessly
entertaining
the opposition you think they can't come
up with anything worse than madder and
then they do
and um you think i'm sure that must be a
satire
and it turns out not to be and uh
they make the same mistakes in the same
order every time
yeah i mean that stuff is endlessly you
know i mean
there are never by the way there's a
very serious ones i mean there was one
that came up the other day the american
psychological association decided to
become a sort of racist organization it
announced that all white people have the
uh have white supremacy a blood
a blood problem basically by being white
and now of course the american
psychological association last year
decided that men were a problem so i i
just sort of think at some point the
american psychological association is
going to have to
refer itself to a psychologist i suppose
but
but but you know they do this on a very
regular basis the un did it today the
u.n
uh declared that uh oh what was it yeah
until we address
oh you know the usual thing it says cis
heteronormativity patriarchy there won't
be peace in the world you think yeah i
don't know if that's going to solve
yemen
um but uh i mean you know it's actually
what you do if you can't solve yemen
isn't it you start jabbering on about
heteronormativity somewhere in geneva
but but uh uh yeah they come up with
things every day
i'm fascinated by that but i also don't
spend all my time on it
or at least let me let me rephrase that
i spend
too much of my time on it but i always
balance it out with something worthwhile
right i literally think of it like
sustenance
if i spend some hours imbibing the
latest crazy [ __ ]
that everyone's doing today i read a
really good book
or i watch a terrific movie i've never
seen so
you're allowed to eat the hamburger as
long as you go and go to the gym at some
point
right i absolutely advise this for
everybody
like the joy of reading old books
the joy of watching old movies you know
just
take a classic movie you never bothered
with or a classic book you've never read
and read it it's the best antidote to it
and by the way it's not just an antidote
it's very important because it reminds
you of how
people lived until the weird era we're
in
it helps give you very basic things that
our era is losing perspective
sense of judgment uh and much more so
that's
i i you know that that really is an
important tip if i can say so um people
cannot imbibe just
what we're being told to imbibe you said
on the trigonometry episode i watched
that was standing on the precipice
and it's interesting to use that word
because i've been thinking about this
for quite a while toby ord who is from
the future of humanities institute at
oxford
um he wrote a book called the precipice
and it's all about existential threat
oh yeah oh yeah yes yes yes i've i've
heard him yes wonderful australian dude
also big into the effective altruism
movement
right yeah yeah yeah i read him on
altruism that's right huge
uh big picture thinking um and he called
his book the precipice
and he gives humanity's chances
of surviving the next century
one in three he gives humanity's chances
of reaching our full potential as a
civilization space faring colonize the
galaxy
at one in two so the vast majority of
our risk as a species
is front loaded within the next century
my concern is that smart people
like you like gad sad like
sam harris are using up brain power
on things that are self-defeating
there's a concept by robin hansen called
the great filter which explains the
fermi paradox why
are there not aliens out there he
suggests that there is a particular
section that we need
to get past and given that some of the
smartest minds of
the last few years have spent an
inordinate amount of time trying to work
out whether men
are women or not to me feels like
that could be that if that's the reason
that as a species we don't reach our
full potential because
we decided to have these stupid tribal
like childish completely idiotic
self-defeating discussions yeah when the
asteroid comes
or a slightly more effective pathogen
hits or
pick your any one of the other
existential risks that toby brings up in
his book
like we did this to ourselves we we
built
it yeah yeah i couldn't agree more i've
said this quite often
in my own defense and if i'm not going
to do it who would
uh the purpose of for instance
management crowds is to give everyone
else a fast
track out uh i can't stress this enough
james lindsey and helen black rose as
you just mentioned
you've spoken with um also do an
excellent
task in a portion of this to do with the
academic
element in their new book um
cynical theories the point is is that
i don't want everyone to spend their
life reading unreadable books
i've read a significant number of them
in order to tell people not to read them
because it's not worth their time
and it's the same with quite a lot of
the subjects i deal with in a manner of
crowds is to say
this doesn't work don't fall for it
this is a ponzi scheme that's a fraud
now that is not because i want to spend
the rest of my life
talking about mad ponzi schemes invented
by frauds
it's because i want everyone else to get
through and all round or across this or
over the top of this
or burrow underneath it however you're
going to do it as fast as possible
it's very hard to do it if you don't
know what you're facing
because if you don't know what you're
facing you've got a disproportionate
likelihood of getting
killed blown up if you know what you're
facing
and you know the shortcut ways through
it's likely you can get on with the rest
of your life
and that's why i did them that's why i
wrote the madness of crowds first of all
and why
i've not now updated it is because i
wanted to stop particularly young people
first of all feeling intimidated by this
including
intellectually intimidated because they
shouldn't feel intellectually
intimidated by this
um secondly for them to realize the
size of the thing that was that they're
being faced with in other words
a total reorganization of everything
which i submit is not going to work
but crucially that in in knowing and
understanding this you can get
through and get on with your life and
this is
this is a very important task because i
absolutely agree that for a lot of us
i mean millions and millions of us
everybody on the planet
we are wasting an opportunity at the
moment and the opportunity is as you
as you describe is that at this
time in our history there is so much we
can do
because we have access to knowledge in a
way that we never did in the past
our forbes had to
have to live with ignorance on a lot of
things a lot of things
and the most obvious one is if you
didn't have access to a book you didn't
know what was in it
who doesn't now have access to a book if
they've got a
relatively small sum of money um
they can join a lending library or they
can
buy a book online you can get a classic
book you can you can get hold of things
very recently our parents generation our
grandparents generation certainly that
wasn't the case
so that's not that's the case in area
after area we live in a time where
instead of being in ignorance about so
many things
you just you can just put it in into a
search engine
and why in that situation are we
spending our time as you say
talking about whether or not intersex
people
with a particular condition are the same
as trans people i mean i i often used to
joke you know this is what what'll
this is what happens when the barbarians
break in you know
we'll all get kalashnikov whilst talking
about gender neutral bathrooms
a horrible last thought to go through
your head
and and i've always thought that and and
as i say
a self-appointed task of mine is to try
to help other people get through that
itself but i stress and i think i said
this the other day to people on
trigonometry
there is also a very very important
thing that people need to bear in mind
which is not to put off what you're
meant to be doing with your life
not to put it off in particular
because you want the conditions of life
to become
optimal i i think i
have it here somewhere i i said to the
trigonometry people the other day i was
reading a sermon that c.s lewis gave in
1939
just at the outbreak of war it's such a
moving sermon because he says in it
um you know these aren't optimal times
but they never were
they never were and as he says if human
beings
put off their search for beauty and
truth
and creation until the times were
optimal
they'd never have got started we would
never have started doing anything
and the thing that's so
desperate about the politicization of
everything
and the reason i say to people please
de-politicize your lives
is because it is not what you were meant
to do it's not what we were meant to do
to spend our time endlessly going around
such issues all of us every single
person watching
you and me all have an enormous amount
that we could do with our life an
enormous amount we can contribute
probably the least positive thing we can
contribute
is to some mass movement that's almost
certainly got enough members anyway
even if it was going in a good direction
and they almost never do
and what you're meant to be doing should
not be put off
until that movement gains total
ascendancy
firstly because it won't secondly
because it will be hell even if it did
so don't put it off whatever it is
you're meant to be doing
but do work out how to survive in this
era
and then get on to doing the thing you
should be doing with your life because i
can assure
every single person watching it is going
to be so much
more damn rewarding than what you're
being offered at the moment
topics like that and that particular
passage that you pulled from the sermon
in 1939
that's what i want more of that's what i
want people like james lindsay with a
phd in
pure mathematics bro stop
just i don't want the world to have he
should be getting us to mars he should
be trying to do
that's what i want to hear i want to
hear more of that um
timeless evergreen wisdom you know that
is going to be the sort of thing that's
usable in 50 years time or 100 years
time
because i agree critical race theory
isn't
[Music]